okay so what exactly is the cloud for
developers cloud computing is all about
getting things done on someone else's
computers so when you're using Google
Cloud you're using Google's scalable and
reliable computers to build and host
applications and store and analyze data
so the cloud is a lot of things
infrastructure storage databases data
analytics networking data science
machine learning and artificial
intelligence resources all on demand and
all over the Internet and since the
cloud does a lot of things it can feel
like there's a lot to learn which is why
we need the Google Cloud Essentials
playlist with getting started videos
console tours and overviews of our
machine learning serverless error
reporting tools and so much more ready
to start your Cloud Learning Journey
check out the link in our bio and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel to
stay up to date on what's new in Google
Cloud